♪ Four and three
♪ and two and one, one
(lively jazz piano music)
- What up guys?
I'm Matt FX, Music
Supervisor of Broad City
and this is our music
recap for episode eight
of season 1,
Destination Wedding.
It's actually a really really
cool episode to talk about
because almost all the music
in this episode is RJD2.
Our episode begins with
a bespoke RJD2 beat
that immediately grips us into
the hurried wedding quest.
The motif was made
specifically for the episode
(RJD2 beat)
- I thought we were all wearing
our old catering
uniforms together.
- Nobody said that dude,
you're supposed to
return it when you quit.
- Oh please.
- Yeah Illana we're not
caterers at Darcy's wedding,
we're guests.
- I know Morgan, thanks.
- Wanted to point out
another dope RJ cut
that you actually
can find online.
The track actually replaced
our theme song for this week,
it's called 1976 and it's off
his record Since We Last Spoke.
It's a really cool Italian Job
sorta feel that lends itself
perfectly to the rushed
feeling of this episode.
("1976" by RJD2)
- Uhh Illana,
why is there to 2:10 train
to Bridgeport anywhere?
- I don't know, I'm
not a conductor!
- And that was our music
recap for episode eight,
Destination Wedding.
Thank you so much
to Ramble, aka RJD2
for letting us work with him
and use some of the
music on the episode.
Really really loved all the
stuff he contributed and
hope you guys enjoyed it too.
Follow me on twitter
@MattFXFXFXFX
Follow Broad City on
Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr
for more music as well
as other cool stuff
and I'll see ya next week.